consider the function f of x is equal to
the natural log of x squared let l of x
be the local linearization of f at a is
equal to e
what is a rule for l of x so let's just
make sure we understand what they are
asking for and i've copied and pasted
this exact exercise on my little scratch
pad so we could work through it so let's
just val let's just visualize what f of
x looks like and what l of x is what the
local linearization
if we are centering it at
x is equal to e if we're saying that
there's the set when they say a that's
just a convention for what are we what
are we approximating around what the
locality the x value that we are
approximating around so let's just
let me graph some points here just to
visualize f of x so let's say this is
one
this is two
this is so actually let me spread them
out a little bit more
so this is 1
this is 2
and this is 3.
f of 1 is going to be 0 the natural log
of 1 squared is just 0. and let's see we
could think of f of e
and that's actually where we're
centering our linearization we're going
to think about values in that locality
so e is roughly right over here
e is right roughly right over here and f
of e
is equal to natural log of v squared is
well that's just going to be 2. so this
is going to be we're going to have 1
and 2.
and so
this is also going to be a point on the
graph and it's going to look something
like this
gonna look something
something like that that's what
that's the graph of y is equal to f of x
y is equal to f of x
now what do they mean when they say the
local the local linearization of f at a
is equal to e
well the convention here is they use the
letter a when they're talking about when
they're talking about local
linearization say okay this is what
we're approximating around so this is
our a value right over here so we're
essentially just going to think about
the slope of the tangent line at that
point or this point e comma f of e so
the l of x
is going to describe
l of x is going to describe
this line right over here
so this is
this right over here is y is equal to
l of x
but we write it in a way that is well
suited for local linearization for
approximating the value of the function
around what for x values
around e so what do we mean by that well
the general way of describing l of x
say that l x
is equal to the function evaluated at
that point that you're centering around
at a
at a so it's going to be this it's going
to be this value right over here
plus the slope of the tangent line today
times how far
times the difference between the x value
that you're approximating
and a and once again why does this make
sense well let's say that you're trying
to approximate
f of this value right over here so the
function evaluated there would be
right over there but we want to use the
local linearization so we essentially
want to say well what is l of this x
value
so we want to figure out what is this
right over here well you start at f of a
which is this
and then you multiply or to that you add
the slope times the difference between
these two values x minus a is this
distance you multiply that times the
slope that's going to give you your
change in y so your change in y plus
this y right over here is going to give
you the y value of that
right over there so this could be useful
for approximating let's say you wanted
to approximate what what the what the
natural log of e plus 0.2 squared is and
so this could could be could be valuable
but let's just work through this for
this particular case
we know that so we're saying that a is
equal to e
so let's replace this is this should be
e
this should be e
and this should be e
and now what is f of e
well this is this right over here is the
natural log of e squared
and now what's f prime of e well let's
just calculate that down here so f prime
of x we can
just use the chain rules uh it's the
derivative of the natural log of x
squared with respect to x squared so
that's going to be 1
over x squared
times the derivative of x squared with
respect to
x so times 2x and so this is going to be
equal to 2 over x
so f prime of e is going to be 2 over e
and then times x minus e
so that's
that's our rule or our definition for l
of x and let's see which one of these
let's see which one of these shows oh
and of course we could have we could
simplify the natural log of e squared
the power that i have to raise e 2 to
get to e square well this is of course
equal to 2. so it's 2 plus 2 over e
times x minus e so 2 plus 2 over e times
x minus e it's that choice right over
there but just to make it clear how this
could be useful let's say that we're
trying to approximate we're trying to
approximate f of e
plus
0.1
so we're trying to approximate that now
like if i just put e plus 0.1 and i
squared and i've had to figure out the
natural log of that without a calculator
that seems hard to me
but now we could use a local
linearization this is going to be we
could say it's approximately
going to be equal to
plus
2 over e
times well what's e plus 0.1 minus e
well it's just going to be 0
0.1 and i guess you probably still need
a calculator to figure this out or you
could just leave it here because anyway
this is a pretty good approximation for
what the natural log of e plus 0.1
squared is going to be equal to
and well let's just let's just
check our answer
so
is that one right there and we got it
right